(bright music)
(keyboard clacking)
- I'd encourage every single one of you
to spend some time immersed
in a different culture
or maybe even spend some time working
in a totally different part of the world
from where you grew up.
And...
It doesn't have to be quite that drastic.
It could be as simple as
investing in relationships
with people from other parts of the world.
And while you're at it,
I'd encourage you to learn
a different language.
Both of those experiences, I think,
will stretch your mind in ways
that help you consider
other possibilities.
- Students can expand their creative
and scientific skill sets
by thinking beyond the classroom
and beyond the textbook,
using that information
from classroom and from the textbook
and from other formal information sources,
and expanding that to learn
more about both today's world
and the world that you
imagine for the future.
That involves using those skills
such as communication,
and problem-solving,
and critical thinking
to wonder not just about
what is already known,
but to wonder about what is not yet known,
which involves using creativity
to think and to wonder.
And that also means
communicating with other people
to see how wanna shape the world as well.
(bright music)